will do my trick club and I came out
successfully on systema second leaving
my wife behind because she was there and
I brought back food when I dog back room
I also discover while I was a de tu my
dog one of my daughters died my little
sister died and a little girl that was
talking with my wife and I also died
Mischka show go away from me our desi
when you operate god Jane teach ok mama
Kris my freezer power loud without meat
I saw name everyone all dainty so they
sketch a lot on my mind they went away
for bit for bit ly disagree thing to
survive Ebola it is a great thing to
survive Ebola i'm walking in the love of
God Oh
you